في خضم حرب غزة هذه الأيام،
تجد المملكة العربية السعودية، الدولة العربية الرائدة، نفسها في مأزق من ناحية،
فهي بالطبع
تشك بطبيعة الحال في منافستها إيران، ومن ناحية
أخرى، فهي تدعم
القضية الفلسطينية وليس لديها علاقات بعد.  لقد
تحدثت مع
وزير الخارجية السعودي فيصل بن فرحان آل ساع
على هامش
الاجتماع السنوي للمنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي في
دافوس، وقد سعد الوزير
بتواجدك هنا، واسمحوا لي أن أبدأ
بالأزمة المطروحة وهي
هجمات الحوثيين.  على السفن
الانتقام الأمريكي كم أنتم قلقون من أن
الأمر قد يخرج عن نطاق السيطرة يعني
بالطبع نحن قلقون للغاية يعني تعلمون
أننا في
وقت صعب وخطير للغاية في المنطقة وأه لهذا
السبب نطالب بخفض
التصعيد  كما تعلمون أننا بالطبع
نؤمن بشدة بحرية
الملاحة وهذا شيء
يجب حمايته ولكننا نحتاج أيضًا إلى
حماية أه أمن واستقرار
المنطقة لذلك نحن أه نركز بشدة
على تهدئة الوضع بقدر
ما  ممكن واسمحوا لي أن أسألكم عن
المنطقة الأخرى التي يقلق الناس فيها أه
لبنان وحزب الله أه ماذا
ترون وما هو مفتاح
التهدئة هناك أعني مفتاح
التهدئة بشكل عام الآن
أعتقد هو إنهاء الصراع في  razza
لأن هذا يغذي كل
عدم الاستقرار في المنطقة، كما تعلمون
كنا بالفعل منطقة غير مستقرة للغاية أه
للأسف من قبل ولكن هذا
الصراع المستمر والمذبحة المستمرة التي
نشهدها كما تعلمون أننا الآن عند
30 ألف قتيل مدني أه في غزة  تعرف أنه علينا أن
نجد طريقة لإيقاف أه هذه
الأزمة أه يجب أن نوقف القتل في
غزة وهذا سيضع الأساس
أعتقد لأه استقرار
الأوضاع الأخرى في جوارهم الآن
هناك من يعتقد أن
الحكومة السعودية قد  لا حب
لحماس أه، لقد اعتبرتها دائمًا
جزءًا من تنظيم الإخوان المسلمين أه، هل
تعرف نوعًا ما
من المعارضين لأنظمة مثل المملكة العربية
السعودية، لذا فأنت لست حزينًا جدًا لأن
الإسرائيليين يسحقون حماس، كما
تتمنى فقط  سيفعلون ذلك بشكل أسرع قليلاً
ولن يكون هناك الكثير من
الضحايا الجانبيين، ولسوء الحظ
ما نراه هو أن الإسرائيليين
يسحقون غزة، إنهم يسحقون
السكان المدنيين في الرزة وهذا غير
ضروري على الإطلاق، إنه
غير مقبول على الإطلاق، وقد حدث ذلك  للتوقف علينا أن
نجد طريقة أه لوقف قتل
المدنيين يجب أن نجد طريقة للسماح بوصول
المساعدات الإنسانية، هل
لديك أه اتصالات غير مباشرة مع
إسرائيل على مر السنين وأنا أتساءل متى
أه تضع هذا  الرسالة التي كنت
تنشرها باستمرار
أم هل تحصل على أي إشارات من
الإسرائيليين بأن الأمور ستتغير
قريبًا يعني ما نراه بالتأكيد في
وسائل الإعلام ما نراه على الأرض
للأسف أه لا يدل على
تغيير أه  تعلمون أكثر ما
يثير القلق هو أنني لا أرى أي
استراتيجية حقيقية أه أه اتجاه أي استراتيجية حقيقية واضحة
وهذا خطير جداً جداً
وكما تعلمون أن المدنيين الأبرياء
في غزة يدفعون الثمن ولكن
ليس مدنيي غزة فقط بل
استقرار المنطقة
نشهد مستويات غير عادية من الغضب
والانزعاج بسبب صور هؤلاء أه
المدنيين وهم يقتلون وغيرهم لذلك
تعلم أننا بحاجة إلى إيجاد طريقة لوقف أه
القتال نحتاج إلى إيجاد طريقة
لمعالجة هذه القضايا  من خلال الحوار
من خلال عملية سياسية، هذه هي
الأولوية، ما رأيك في
الخطوة التالية الأكثر منطقية؟ هل ستكون المملكة العربية السعودية على
استعداد لأن تكون جزءًا من
قوة عربية تدخل لتحل محل
الإسرائيليين وتحقيق الاستقرار في غزة، نعم أعتقد أن
ما نحتاج إلى التركيز عليه  هو حل
للقضية الفلسطينية وليس
لغزة فقط. أعتقد أن جميع الدول العربية
أشارت إلى أنها مستعدة للحديث
عن حل أو حل
يتضمن كيفية إدارة الوضع في
غزة طالما أنه جزء من حل أكبر.
الصورة كما تعلمون وما نرى أنه
ضروري هو شكل من أشكال
الدولة الفلسطينية ذات المصداقية التي لا رجعة فيها والتي
ستعطي الشرعية لأي دولة أه عربية
وأنتم تعرفوننا كمجموعة جماعية
تعالج القضية أه
بشكل شمولي بما في ذلك بالطبع الرزة
وحكم الرزة لذلك  أنت
لا تستبعد إمكانية إرسال
قوات سعودية إلى القوات السعودية، أعتقد أن هذا
شيء تعرفه افتراضيًا ومن
الصعب معالجته، وحتى القوات العربية
هي لا أعتقد أن نوع القوة على
الأرض هو المشكلة، لأنه إذا
كنا  تقديم أمل حقيقي للفلسطينيين
أعتقد أنه سيكون في حدود
قدرة الشعب الفلسطيني أه الشعب
السلطة الفلسطينية أه على تحمل
تلك المسؤولية نفس السؤال مع
إعادة الإعمار كما تعلمون أن
هذا أحد المجالات التي
يأمل الناس في السعودية  ستلعب
دورًا كبيرًا لأنك تمتلك
ثروة هائلة، فهل المملكة العربية السعودية مستعدة
لتمويل إعادة إعمار غزة؟
أعني أنه لا فائدة من الحديث عن
إعادة إعمار غزة إذا لم نكن
نتحدث عن إنهاء
القتل مرة أخرى أولاً طالما  نظرًا لأننا قادرون على إيجاد
طريق نحو حل،
حل، مسار يعني أننا
لن نكون هنا مرة أخرى خلال
عام أو عامين، فيمكننا التحدث عن
أي شيء ولكن إذا كنا فقط نعيد ضبط
الوضع الراهن  قبل السابع من تشرين الأول (أكتوبر)
بطريقة تؤهلنا
لجولة أخرى من هذا كما رأينا في
الماضي، نحن لسنا مهتمين بهذه
المحادثة، لذلك دعونا نتحدث عن
هذا المسار السياسي، وهو ما
تقوله وما ستفعله  تكون على
استعداد لتكون جزءًا من الحل مع ما
يتعلق بالفلسطينيين وأعتقد أنك
قلت في الماضي علنًا
أنك ستكون على استعداد لمواصلة
التحرك نحو أه المناقشات مع إسرائيل
حول
التطبيع إذا وفقط إذا كان هناك ما
تقوله  مسار لا رجعة فيه نحو
إقامة دولة فلسطينية، وبعبارة أخرى، ليس
مجرد محادثات ومحادثات، بل خطة
تبدو بالنسبة لكم لا رجعة فيها على الإطلاق،
وأعتقد أن هذا هو إجماع
الجميع في
المجتمع الدولي عندما أتحدث إلى الأوروبيين
حتى عندما أعرف ما أعرفه.  نسمع من
الأمريكان الجميع متفق على
أه السبيل الوحيد للخروج من
دائرة العنف هو أن نكون حتما على
هذا الطريق إلى الدولة الفلسطينية
وهذا ضروري للغاية وهذا
ما نركز
عليه